hey guys Pete here I was rereading one
of the sample winds of winter chapters
which I don't really want to go into but
something happened that reminded me of a
theory that is related to the stark
family and their dire wolves this video
will lay out the theory and contain
spoilers and speculation related to
everything that's happened through
season six also I'm starting a giveaway
for subscribers so make sure you watch
until the end to learn more about that
each of Ned Stark's children have a
direwolf that they've raised from the
time they were pops if you don't
remember how they came into possession
of them it happened in the first episode
of season 1 in the show and in the very
first point of view chapter in the first
book the scene in the show is pretty
much the same so let's give it a watch
and take a trip down memory lane it's a
freak it's a direwolf
[Music]
so far waste
there are no direwolves south of the
wall now there are five
want to hold it where will they go
their mother's dead I don't belong down
here better a quick death no won't last
without their mother right give it to
you no put away your blade take orders
from your father not you please father
I'm sorry Brad
Lord Stark there are five pups one for
each of the stark children the direwolf
is the sigil of your house they were
meant to have them we'll train them
yourselves you'll feed them yourselves
and if they die you will bury them
yourselves
what about you I'm not a stark get up
what is it
Rome to the litter that one's yours snow
we learned that dire wolves don't belong
south of the wall and that they haven't
been seen there for 200 years no one
offers any ideas on how a dire wolf
might make its way through the wall so
that part remains a mystery there is a
lot of symbolism involved in the scene
though in the show we see a dead stag
which is how the mother got killed in
the first place at first they find five
pups which is the right number of true
born children that the Starks have and
the final pup who becomes John is an
oddball and the runt
the stag is the sigil of house Baratheon
and the direwolf is on Stark sigil
they're coming together led to their
mutual demise so you could say that this
foreshadows Ned and Robert's fates at
the end of this first season so how did
this lone pregnant dire wolf make its
way south of the wall and happen to die
by getting into a battle with a stag
right and the path of the Starks who are
returning home after the execution of
the man who deserted the Nights Watch it
could be just one of those things that
happens a coincidence that sets things
in motion basically it happened because
it had to happen or there may have been
another unseen force at play now keep in
mind what is important here is that it
did happen
the direwolves are an essential part of
the story as they wake up the stark
children's telepathic abilities and the
books they have wolf dreams which is a
whole other video but if they haven't
come across these particular pups at
this time it isn't clear if they would
have learned about this connection
another thing to keep in mind is that
this is the very first scene that george
RR martin came up with that led him down
the path of building this world so the
dire wolves are not just cool but
they're very important to the overall
story so the theory goes it wasn't
coincidence that they came across the
pups instead it was the three-eyed Raven
or the three-eyed crow and the books who
sent them other direwolf south and
basically pulled the strings for this
entire encounter now I'm a big fan of
three-eyed Raven in general which we
know is a character named Brendan rivers
in the books and this makes me a little
bit more likely to accept the theory but
let's look at the evidence because it's
kind of interesting direwolves haven't
been seen south of the wall for two
hundred years at this point they are
basically mythical creatures as no
living
and from the you know below the wall
would have ever seen one even though in
the books in show we've been all over
the place including done a good amount
of traveling north of the wall we don't
have any other direwolf sightings of
note as the stark children travel around
with their wolves people seem to
recognize what they are but no one we've
met seems to be familiar with seeing
dire wolves on a regular basis in the
wild so it could certainly be a
coincidence or an example of fate but
the odds of it happening naturally are
pretty astronomical why would the
three-eyed raven be involved well he
says in a dream that he has been
watching brands since he was born
brands gifts are super rare and through
dreams bloodraven guides him to travel
beyond the wall sending the wolves when
introduced brand to his working
abilities and also offers some
protection on his journey there are
several examples of the Wolves loyalty
to the children and in brands case his
direwolf summer saved his life when it
would be assassin tried to kill him
this was back whenever he was in a coma
after falling from the tower I think the
reasons why the three-eyed Raven want to
send the wolves are pretty clear so the
real question is is he able to do
something like this as most things
involving magic prophecy and religion in
the Song of Ice and Fire it's definitely
up for debate or more importantly it's
written in such a way that will lead to
a debate we have quite a few instances
that we could say Bloodraven intervened
in situations while skin changing into
Ravens the classic example is when Jon
brings the fallen brothers of the Nights
Watch back to Castle black and they end
up turning into White's as they advance
on gr and Jon they seem immune to all
manner of attack in the books Vermont's
Raven actually helps out by calling the
word burn and he seems to do this on his
own initiative
John grabs a curtain he caught on fire
and is able to defeat the white by
burning it so if you believe that the
Bloodraven intervened here which a lot
of people do it isn't that much of a
stretch that he might have sent the
direwolf south to be found by the Starks
in conclusion I think there's a good
chance that the three-eyed Raven was
involved but I don't think we will ever
know for sure there's no indisputable
evidence so it's just a fun theory to
think about I said it was a fan of blood
Raven but I'm not that like on the
extreme end of the spectrum in the camp
that thinks like blood Ravens behind the
scenes controlling everything I think he
has a pretty definite plan and that's
the
train train brain and I think that you
know sending the direwolf south does
actually fit into that plan so what do
you guys think did the Starks find the
pups purely by accident or are there
other forces at play let me know what
you think in the comments or just tell
me which direwolf is your favorite do
you think we will seem Nymeria and Aria
reunion before the end of the series
fore I go I'm excited to say that we're
coming up on 13,000 subscribers which is
awesome and to celebrate I decided to
start a giveaway that'll work like this
when my channel reaches 18,000
subscribers I'll pick one of you guys at
random and send you this copy of the
night of the seven kingdoms which I just
picked up it's a collection of the first
three duncan egg stories they put
together with added illustrations and
it's a really great volume and
especially if you haven't read them yet
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video please like this video if you
enjoyed it and don't forget to let me
know what you think about the theory
thanks for watching and I'll talk to you
soon